Power's coming in. Power set. Flow
pressure is in the green. Air speed's
coming alive. A little bit slower. We
got some wind today.
And it's pretty gusty out.
Going to force it on the ground. We're
going to rotate slightly late just
because of these winds.
There it is.
If you want to be a safe pilot, you need
to have a good understanding of the
weather you'll be dealing with before
you go fly. So today I want to explain
some aviation weather products you need
to know how to use.
Save position.
When it comes to weather products,
there's a lot of places you can get your
information. A lot of people like 1800
weather brief. If you have forflight,
it's really easy to get all the
information you need. But it's important
to know that ForeFlight doesn't actually
make all these products. They actually
come from the National Weather Service.
So, even if you use forflight, you
should really take the time to look at
these websites and understand how to use
some of their products for flight
planning. Now, if you didn't already
know, the National Weather Service has
its own website specifically for pilots
called aviationweather.gov.
And if we pull up this website, you can
see that there's a lot of useful
information on here. But today, I'm just
going to show you some of the main
products you should be using when you
fly. I'm also going to go into a lot of
detail on how to read the winds of loft
data, which you're going to be using a
lot when you do your cross-country
planning. And even if you have
forflight, you need to know how to do
this because the DPE might have you do
this on your check ride. I'm also going
to go into a lot more detail on some of
the aviation forecast charts and how to
read them. But first, let's go back to
the homepage and take a look at where
you can get your TAPS and MEARS. And as
you can see, they've made things super
easy on us here. There's a tab for each
of them on the home screen. Let's click
on the MEAR tab and check it out. Now,
let's slide down here to this little
spot that says request MEAR data. Now,
you can just type in whatever airport
identifiers you want and search for
them. Let's see. Let's try KTL, KICT,
and KMEM. Now, I like to click this
include TAF button, and it will give you
the Taffs and MEARS at the same time.
Then, we'll just click this button that
says get MEAR data. And as you can see,
we have the most up-to-date MEARS and
tasks for each airport. The MEARS are at
the top and the Taffs are right below
that. Then, if we go back to the home
screen, you can click the TAPS button
here. And as you can see, you can get
the same information that way as well.
And I'm not going to explain how to read
these today because I did that in the
last video. If you don't want to watch
that, I'll put a link in the description
for you. Okay, now that I've shown you
that, let's find the winds of loft
tables and discuss how to read those.
Let's go up here to the forecast tab,
then down to the wind/temps.
Then we'll scroll down to this chart
that says wind/temps data. As you can
see, if you hover over the map, a lot of
this data is grouped by region. So, just
click on the area where you're going to
be flying. And I'll go ahead and click
on this South Central region because
that's where I'm going to be flying
today. And now you'll notice there's a
bunch of raw data in here. Don't worry,
it's not as bad as it looks and you only
need a tiny part of the information on
this screen. And you don't really need
to check this every time you go fly.
You'll mainly only be using this when
you go to plan your cross country
flights. You might also consider using
it if you suspect there's some wind
shear when you're flying. Hopefully, I
can talk more about that in an upcoming
episode. And like I said, this
information is mainly used for
cross-country planning, but you're also
likely to get asked how to read this on
your written exam. Okay, before I
explain how to read this, let's make
sure we're getting the right data here.
Most of us here are going to be using
the low-level wind data. Then make sure
you choose the appropriate time. I'll
choose this one cuz that's when I'll be
flying. And this is based on the map we
clicked on earlier. Okay, so now we see
that this information was observed on
the 3rd of the month at 1200 Zulu and
it's current until the fourth day of the
month at 0u. The time we'll be flying is
in between these. So, this is the wind
data that we need. And this is just
telling you that they're too lazy to put
a minus sign on the temperatures at the
last few columns. Now, we'll just scroll
down to the closest airports where we'll
be flying and pick the altitude that
we'll be flying at. Okay, let's zoom in
a little bit and take a closer look at
the forecasted winds of loft. Let's say
we're flying somewhere near Adams Field
or LIIT. Now, as you can see, there are
a few altitudes to choose from. We want
to select the closest altitude to the
altitude we're flying at. As you can
see, we can pick 3,000, 6,000, 9,000,
and so on. So, let's say I'll be flying
close to 6,000 ft. This is the column I
would use. Next, we want to choose the
airport we're going to be closest to.
So, I'll move across from LIT to this
little grouping of information in the
6,000 ft column. Now, the first two
numbers in this group of information is
the wind direction, but you have to add
a zero to the end of that. So, the wind
direction in this example is 2110 or
210° out of the southwest. Now one thing
to keep in mind on these wind directions
is that the direction is relative to
true north not magnetic north and this
is actually true with a lot of other
wind products like taps mears and
surface analysis charts as broadcast
asos and awas and wind data that ATC
gives you will be in reference to
magnetic north. Now these second two
digits here are the wind speed and these
are in knots just as all speeds in
aviation should be. I hate reading those
older gauges in miles hour. That drives
me nuts. So now you can see that a wind
speed at 6,000 ft MSL is 2110 at 19
knots. And this is really important to
know when you're planning a
cross-country flight because if I'm
traveling on a heading of 2110 and my
indicated air speed is 100 knots, my
speed over the ground is now only 81
knots. This is what we call our ground
speed. If my ground speed is slower,
that means it will take me longer to get
to my destination. And we need to know
how long it will take to get there so we
don't run out of fuel. Now, occasionally
you might see the wind data shown with a
like we do here at KBNA in Memphis. This
is just letting you know that the wind
here at this altitude is variable and
less than 5 knots. All right. So now, if
we look back at our data, you'll see
that there are two more numbers here
with a plus or minus sign in front of
them. This is the temperature of the air
at that altitude in Celsius, not
Fahrenheit. Pilots don't use Fahrenheit,
and quite frankly, I wish we'd abolish
it all together. So that means our
temperature at 6,000 ft above Adams
Field is expected to be positive 10° C.
Notice here at Memphis at 12,000 ft MSL,
the temperatures are expected to be a
-2. That's how simple these are to read.
Now, as I mentioned earlier, this note
just lets us know that all these temps
in the columns above 24,000 ft are
negative. So above Adam's field at
34,000 ft, the temperature is 52°. I
guess they just didn't want to deal with
that minus sign. Oh yeah, and for some
reason they don't usually put a
temperature on this 3000 ft column. This
is close enough to the surface that you
could just grab the mear and calculate
the temperature using a standard lapse
rate. Do you remember what that is?
Smash like if you do. All right, now
let's go into a little bit more detail
on the aviation forecast. Let's click on
this forecast tab again and then scroll
down to the aviation forecast tab and
see what's in here. Now, if you watch my
video on the weather basics, this
aviation surface forecast probably looks
familiar to you, but I didn't really
explain a lot of what these symbols and
colors mean. So, let's go ahead and take
a few minutes to do that. Now, these
aviation forecasts are really handy
because you can get a pretty decent
picture of the weather, even if you're
flying somewhere where there's no taps
or mears. When you look at these
forecast charts, there are basically two
different types. The aviation surface
forecast, which is what you see here,
gives us a good idea of the weather on
the surface. While the aviation cloud
forecast is great because it can help
you determine if you're going to be able
to fly VFR because it gives you a good
picture of what the clouds are going to
look like. All right, let's go back to
aviationweather.gov and talk about some
things. Now that we've pulled up this
chart, you can see right now that we
have the aviation surface forecast
selected, and there are actually a few
options here at the top. And if we
wanted to take a look at our cloud
forecast, we could click right here and
get a really good look at the clouds
across the US. We'll discuss this more
in a minute, but let's go back to the
surface forecast for now. And as you can
see, we can zoom in to different regions
and get a more detailed picture of the
weather situation. But for now, we'll
just take a look at the continental
United States. Now, one other thing
that's really important when you're
looking at these charts is to pick the
correct time. The weather can change a
lot in just a few hours, so make sure
you're getting good information. Let's
say I'll be flying in the next 3 hours.
This is the chart I want to look at.
Now, let's talk about some of these
symbols. So, the first thing I notice
when I look at one of these charts are
the wind barbs. These are great because
they give you a good picture of the wind
speed and direction no matter where you
are in the country. As I've mentioned in
my weather basics video, these little
flags seem to fly backwards and the end
without the flag is the direction the
wind is moving. For example, the winds
here in central New Mexico are coming
almost directly from the west. Down in
central Texas, winds are out of the
south, maybe slightly out of the
southeast. Once again, we always
reference where the winds are coming
from. I'm sure someone here didn't know
that before watching this video. Okay.
Now, for the wind speeds, you need to
look at these little flags at the top of
the pole. One line represents 10 knots
of wind. A small line represents 5 knots
of wind. A triangle-shaped pennant
represents 50 knots. So, to get the wind
speed, we add all these up to get the
total. In this example, the wind speed
is 65 knots because 50 + 10 + 5 = 65.
What about this one? I know for the 10
knot line and the five knot line, it
might be tough to tell the difference
when there's only one line. That's why
if there's only five knots of wind, they
don't put the line all the way at the
end of the flag pole. That makes things
a little bit easier. Now, on some of
these charts, you may see red flags on
the wind barbs. These represent gusts.
So, for example, it looks like the winds
in South Carolina are going to be out of
the northwest at 5 knots, gusting to 15.
Seems like pretty decent winds for
practicing touchandgoes to me. Looks
like here in Oklahoma City area, winds
will be out of about 1 190 at 20 knots,
gusting to 30. That sounds like even
more fun. Do you have any strategies for
combating gusty winds on landing? Let me
know what they are in the comments
below. I'd like to share some of mine in
a future episode. There you go. Right
there. There you go. Good corrections.
traffic phenom 16 whiskey fox 2 mile
final runway 23 north
good man that was that was actually
really good now let's take a look at
these shaded areas to make things easy
you'll notice here that there's a key at
the bottom as you can see up here over
Lake Superior we have this purple shaded
area lets us know that we can expect
visibility between zero and one statute
miles pink areas like this means light
IFR with visibility between one and
three statute miles. Blue lets us know
that visibility is between three and
five statute miles. We call this
marginal VFR because in some types of
airspace, you're required to have more
visibility. Then all this white area
lets you know that you can expect
visibility better than five statute
miles. Now, sometimes the National
Weather Service issues additional
weather data specifically for VFR
pilots. These are called AirMeds and
this stands for airman's meteorological
information.
Now, as I just said, these are
specifically made for VFR pilots,
specifically pilots flying single engine
light aircraft. But all pilots should
pay attention to airmets because it can
let you know about weather that might be
hazardous to you. One thing they won't
tell you about though is convective
activity or thunderstorms. They have a
different advisory called a convective
segment to tell you about those. With
that in mind, there are three different
types of airmets. Air Sierra, Airmet
Tango, and Air Zulu. Anytime there's an
airmet sierra, this lets you know that
you can expect a ceiling less than a
th000 f feet and or visibility of less
than three statute miles in that area.
It can also let you know when mountains
are going to be obscured if you do any
mountain flying. An airmet tango lets
you know that you're probably going to
see some moderate turbulence and that's
not very much fun in a small airplane.
It can also mean that the winds on the
surface are going to be above 30 knots
for a decent amount of time. This one's
easy to remember because t is for tango
and t is also for turbulence. An airmet
zulu on the other hand can let you know
about moderate icing in that area.
Moderate icing is one of the scariest
weather situations a pilot can deal
with. Airplanes don't fly too well with
a lot of ice build up on the wings. I
remember Airat Zulu means icing because
water freezes at 0 degrees C and zero
starts with a Z in case you didn't know
that. Now, as you can see, these purple
shaded areas are AirT Sierras. So,
either the visibility is below three
statute miles or the clouds are below
1,000 ft AGL. I bet the clouds are the
problem out here off the coast of
California because there's only a tiny
spot of bad visibility and the rest is
showing to be more than five statute
miles. Then up here in South Dakota, I
mean South Dakota, this tan shaded area
is an airmet tango. Looks like this one
is because of surface winds, not
turbulence. Oh yeah, look at this wind
flag. It's showing 30 knots gusting to
40. Who here is ready to go practice
some touchand goes with me up there? Now
we've got some weird green dots in a few
places. And don't forget, we have this
cheat sheet down here at the bottom.
This green lets us know that they're
expecting some rain up here. And the
darker the green, the better chance you
have of getting some rain. Anytime you
see two dots like this, you can expect
light rain. Three dots indicates
moderate rain. I don't actually see any
of those on this chart. A single dot
with a triangle underneath it just lets
you know that you're probably going to
see some light rain showers. Can you
guess what two blue snowflakes like this
mean? Yep, light snow. And once again,
they're darker. So the chance of getting
this is very likely, greater than 60%.
And as you can see, the snow symbols
work a lot like the rain symbols do
because a snowflake with a triangle
means snow showers. Now, if you glance
up here in New York, you'll notice a
purple dot and a snowflake, and this
means a mix of light snow and rain. Now,
sometimes, especially in these IFR
areas, you might see three yellow lines.
These would indicate fog in these areas.
The nice thing is that even if you don't
know exactly what these symbols mean,
you can get pretty close at guessing by
looking down at these color charts. I
may not know exactly what this symbol
means, but because it's purple, I know
it's some kind of watery icy mix. And
I'd be close because this is the symbol
for ice pellets. We can see down here
that the orange means ice. So, if I saw
this symbol, I know we're looking at icy
conditions. This particular symbol means
light freezing rain. So, let's add
another dot and see if you can guess
what it is. Now, if you said moderate to
heavy freezing rain, you'd be right. Add
a little splash of color and things get
super simple. But with that in mind, if
you ever open this thing up and you
can't figure out what something means,
like this dollar sign, just scroll down
and click this little button labeled
weather symbols, then you'll be able to
decipher these really quickly. Looks
like the dollar sign means blowing dust
or sand. Pretty cool, right? Now, let's
switch to the aviation cloud forecast
and see how easy this one is to read.
And once again, you can see that they
give you the answers down here at the
bottom. And you can zoom in to get a
more detailed picture of each region.
And just like the surface forecast, you
can choose the time you need so you can
see how the cloud situation is going to
progress. Let's take a closer look at
this north central region. Before we
talk about the clouds, I want to point
out this airmet. Notice that in all
these clouds, we have an airmet for
icing. Do you remember what that one is?
Yep. It's an airmet zulu. Remember Z is
for 0 degrees freezing. Okay, so now
let's take a look at these clouds. Once
again, they're color-coded, and this
just makes it way too easy. As I
mentioned in the last video, few and
scattered clouds don't constitute a
ceiling. Both of these layers are
indicated on our charts with gray. And
as you can see, they tell you on
different spots on the chart exactly
where these layers are. Notice here that
these clouds are few at 12,000 ft MSL.
You heard right, MSL. I don't know why
they give you these numbers in MSL, but
if you want to find your cloud height in
AGL, you'll have to subtract the ground
elevation in that area. I have no clue
what the elevation here is, but if it
was 2,000 ft, that would mean these
clouds are at 10,000 ft AGL. Next to
those, we have scattered clouds at
11,000 ft MSL. And guess what? These are
gray as well and still not a ceiling.
Add a splash of blue. Then we start
getting into some happy broken clouds,
which are a ceiling. And the dark blue
lets us know that it's overcast there.
Now, as we look at this chart, you
probably notice all these little dots
that are evenly spread out throughout
this chart. Now, these don't represent
cities or anything. These just show you
the approximate location of those
forecasted clouds. Conveniently, you'll
notice these clear dots in areas where
the sky is clear. That's what this SKC
means. These charts will even show you
when there's serious clouds in the area.
Can anybody tell me why I might want to
know that? Okay, so let's take a look at
some of the other information that you
may see around these dots. Now, as I
just mentioned, these show us where the
base of the clouds are in MSL. But
underneath that data, sometimes you'll
find the altitude, where the tops of the
clouds are in MSL. Up here in North
Dakota, you can see that the overcast
layer starts at 6,000 ft MSL and extends
to 18,000 ft. You're not going to be
flying VFR over the top of these bad
boys. This overcast layer starts at
12,000 ft and extends up to 13,000. So,
this is a pretty thin layer. Right here,
we have a few clouds at 13,000, then
cirrus clouds above that. Now, notice
these charts can also depict multiple
layers, so that can come in pretty handy
as well. These are some of my favorite
charts to look at if I'm trying to get
an idea of what the clouds are going to
look like for the day. VFR pilots really
need to pay attention to these because
we need to avoid clouds when we fly.
Let's take a look at a couple other
things on here. I'll go up here to
observations, then click this button
that says aircraft reports. This is
where you'll find some great
information. These are what we call
pilot reports or pirates. These are
actual pilots giving reports of actual
conditions they're experiencing. To me,
these are a very reliable resource for
pilots when they just need a little bit
more information on the weather. I'm
thinking about making a video on
deciphering this data because it can
also be kind of difficult to read. Let
me know if you'd be interested in that.
Now, if we click on forecast again and
scroll down to the Prague charts in
here, you'll find some more products
that you're going to need to be familiar
with when you go to take your written
exam. I'll probably need to make a
separate video on these low-level Prague
charts because you're going to need to
know that information. But, if you
notice, I've already given a pretty
decent breakdown of the surface plot in
my weather basics video. One more thing
you might find handy on this website is
if you click here on observations, then
click radar. And in here you'll find a
picture of the radar, which I'm sure
we're all familiar with. But if you need
just a little bit more detail on the
cloud situation, this satellite view is
pretty handy as well. See how much you
learned just from watching a simple
YouTube video, you might as well keep
the trend going. Here's a video right
here I'm sure you'll like. See you over
there.
[Music]